Claudia: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in Italy and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In Italy, our drinks come in three sizes,
small, medium, and large.
We're going to measure the large one
to see how much it actually contains.
There's supposed to be 500 ml.
I think we're getting
close to 600, actually.
140 ml extra.
Burger King in the US.
Our fountain drinks come in four sizes,
value, small, medium, and large,
and the large is 38 fluid ounces,
or 1,120 milliliters.
And now I would like
to measure the largest
and see if that's exactly
how much they gave us.
It's almost exactly 32 fluid ounces.
It's not close to 38 ounces.
Yeah, it says 38 in the bottom here.
Hey, someone who works at Burger King
or someone who works in fast food,
why, why, why, do they say
here's how big the cup is
and then clearly it's not that amount?
What am I missing here?
Every single place does it.
Here in Italy we have
three sizes of fries,
small, medium, and large.
Burger King in the US,
they got four fries sizes.
Over here's the value, then the small,
the medium, and the large.
So, I know that in "Food Wars" history,
Burger King has actually lied to us.
So let's see if they've been
honest with me today in Italy
and measure every single one of them.
The sizes are working now.
The small is actually
smaller than the medium.
I have no proof of this.
I think they saw our US
versus UK Burger King episode,
saw us then call out #frygate2021,
whenever we did that.
#frygate2020!
And they're running
scared, but they still,
trying to pull it over.
A US Whopper.
The Whopper's a fantastic sandwich.
On to the nuggets. In Italy,
they come in three sizes,
a six-piece, nine-piece, and 20-piece.
In the US, our nuggets
come in three sizes,
two if you go into the
restaurant apparently.
You can get the four-piece
or the eight-piece,
but also on Uber Eats,
an exclusive apparently,
you can get a 16-piece.
Both Italy and the US serve onion rings.
In Italy, they come in a eight-piece,
12-piece, and 16-piece.
So, we have four onion-ring sizes,
and I want to point out that for us,
we just do it by cup size.
We're not doing it by
number of onion rings
like they do in Italy.
I have to say, they were very generous
with the onion rings at ours.
I mean, this is the value.
This thing is overflowing
with onion rings.
We have a small, medium, and large.
Here's everything that you can
find at Burger King in Italy
that you won't find in the US.
And here's everything you can find
on the menu at a US Burger
King you can't get in Italy.
Let's start with the burgers.
In Italy, we have the
Italian King collection,
which comprises these two burgers here.
The first one is the Parma
ham and scamorza burger.
Scamorza is a cheese from
south Italy, where I'm from.
So, scamorza, it's a bit
like a mozzarella in a way,
like they come from the
same family of cheeses.
They're made in a similar way,
but scamorza, it's aged for, like, a week,
like, not so much, so it's
like a hard mozzarella.
Let's see how it tastes in a burger.
Nice.
Not a fan of the onions.
I think they overpower a little
bit the taste of the cheese.
Without maybe the patty,
it does seem like a
traditional Italian sandwich.
And then we have the Parmesan burger.
This one has bacon in it.
Apparently when Burger
King launched this burger,
they had to buy something like
500 wheels of Parmigiano-Reggiano,
which is like Parmesan. In
Italy they are the same thing.
So quite a lot of wheels.
I don't know. It feels like a dream
to be in one of those rooms
with 500 wheels of Parmesan.
It feels like, I don't know,
next time you do it, please
call me, Burger King.
I'm coming to collect the cheese.
Better this one than the other one.
This one is a little bit less messy.
The flavors come out individually.
I can taste everything.
Yeah, I like this one.
Always on the Parmesan team.
And then we've got the big king.
This is supposed to be Burger
King's version of the Big Mac.
This one, it's slightly
different to the US
because it has an extra bun in the middle,
and apparently it has a special sauce
that's supposed to taste
like Thousand Island sauce.
Very yellowy.
I never had Thousand Island sauce.
I don't think I've ever seen
it, even in a supermarket.
This is a bit vinegary,
a bit like tartar sauce in a way,
but, mm, I don't know.
I'm not a fan, but I don't
know, maybe there's just, like,
the aftertaste of pickles.
That's also something I don't like.
I know Joe doesn't like them,
so, yeah, there's two of us.
Yes, Claudia dislikes pickles, too!
I'm so happy to hear that.
Claudia has impeccable taste.
So for her to dislike pickles
must mean that I also
have impeccable taste.
So me and Claudia, no-pickle friends.
And then we've got the
bacon burger king 3.0.
It's got three of everything.
It's got three patties, three cheeses,
and actually eight strips of bacon.
It's so heavy.
I mean, I'm going to take this to the gym
to use as a proper weight.
It just looks gross.
It looks like, I don't know, like cement.
I don't know how this is
an exclusive to Italy.
I feel like if I want to indulge,
I'll just have two of something else
that's a little bit less messy.
There are eight strips of bacon, though,
and apparently they are different
in Italy than in the US.
So let's have a look.
And then we've got the Bronx steakhouse.
If you are from the Bronx,
does this look familiar to you?
And then we have the
veggie steakhouse.
Same thing, just with a
veggie party. What is this?
It's like veggie bacon. It's
the first time I see it.
Why is it brown? It looks like a candy.
Tastes like salt and like frying oil.
Not so much like bacon.
Yeah, does give you the feeling
of just having a regular burger.
This is not technically vegetarian
because it's cooked on the
same grill as the meat patty.
I guess this is a burger
for people that eat meat
that want to try a veggie option.
The veggie steakhouse?
That might be a translation error.
I don't know if it could be
a veggie and a steakhouse.
Then we've got the big king XXL,
so bigger size than this one.
This one has got two
patties, four cheeses,
and a special sauce.
Bigger onions as well.
Then we have the plant-based Whopper,
and then we've got the
crazy cheese Whopper.
This one is a delivery exclusive,
apparently for the cheese lovers.
To be honest, as a cheese lover,
what is this amount of cheese?
Just, it's ridiculous.
There was more in any other burger.
It's just for the lovers of, like,
weirdly hanging strips of bacon, maybe.
All right, US burger exclusive options,
starting right here.
Got the bacon cheeseburger.
Look how small this is, by the way.
But as you can see, burger,
got bacon and cheese. Believe it.
Moving on to the Impossible Whopper.
I think that's this one with lettuce. Yep.
Impossible is a brand of plant-based meat
here in the United
States that is just that,
made from plants! No animals were harmed
in the making of this burger, I think.
Something that should be noted,
there is a disclaimer on the
Burger King website that says,
"Our Impossible meat is
cooked on the same broiler
as the regular meat," and
also the mayo on these burgers
does have eggs in it, so, good effort?
Texas double Whopper. Come on, Texas.
Texas is a state in the United States
that does everything bigger,
so of course they have their own Whopper.
It's a double Whopper, double
the size of a regular Whopper.
Look at this. It's got
double the meat. See that?
And jalapeños on here,
although they're kind of
nonexistent, but they're on there.
In the US, we have the
single quarter-pound king.
You saw that earlier. I
absolutely destroyed it.
I threw it away. But also we
have a single Impossible king!
Same thing as the Impossible Whopper!
Why am I talking like this? Look at that.
I mean, you could put this melted cheese
on a piece of shoe leather,
and I wouldn't know the difference.
We also have a bacon Whopper Jr.,
which they didn't give us,
also a big king, which
they did not give us.
I'm certain I ordered it.
Anyway, what we do have is this,
the Rodeo burger, pa-pow.
It's a burger with barbecue
sauce and onion rings.
Man, really generous with the onion rings.
Fun fact about the Rodeo cheeseburger:
It was created to
coincide with the release
of the film "Small Soldiers" in 1998.
Another fun fact: In 1998,
I worked at a movie theater
in Schaumburg, Illinois,
that showed "Small Soldiers."
This was for some reason brought out
in time with that movie.
It was on the dollar
menu, stayed on the menu.
I guess you can see
why. Fun little burger.
And the "Small Soldiers" Chip Hazard,
which is the name of the character,
I didn't even know what his name was,
advertised it by saying,
"You can't handle the Rodeo
burger," which is just like
Jack Nicholson's line
from "A Few Good Men,"
"You can't handle the truth!"
Here are all the chicken items
that you can get at Burger King in Italy,
starting from the Crunchicken.
Fried chicken, mayo, lettuce, and tomato.
You can also get a chicken bacon king,
same thing as the beef one,
with eight strips of bacon.
Next up we have the chicken
royale, with bacon, cheese.
Why is this this shape?
Does this look royal to you?
Maybe it's just easier to eat.
I don't know, but I'm not very intrigued.
A lot of mayo here.
And then we got the
crazy cheese chicken BBQ.
Yeah, there's definitely
barbecue sauce here.
And then we got a
plant-based nugget burger,
which has mayo that is not vegan
because obviously there's eggs in there,
but there are three nuggets in there.
Just quite funny, like a nugget burger.
Here are most of the chicken options
you can get at the US Burger King.
Starting down here, we got
the BK royal crispy chicken.
Every time we do a "Food Wars,"
Burger King's got a bunch
of new chicken sandwiches
because they're trying to
compete with Chick-fil-A,
and if you ask me, they losing.
All right. This looks like
the epitome of "just OK."
We also have a spicy version
of the same sandwich,
the spicy BK royal crispy sandwich.
This one looks crispier.
Much better. Not very spicy.
Good flavor to it. Get that one.
You also have a bacon and Swiss one,
which I think is this one.
All right. I'm going to
get a bite of the bacon
and the Swiss.
Tastes bacony.
Typical to Burger King,
something's popular,
so they make a somewhat inferior version.
You can also get the honey mustard
BK royal crisp chicken blabbity blah.
[groans]
This one also has bacon on it.
The honey mustard's interesting.
We also have a chicken
junior. It's a little guy.
This is basically the
rip-off of the McChicken,
a far more superior chicken sandwich.
Another menu item that was
available over the summer
but may be off the menu now,
certainly wasn't at the BK
we went to here in Burbank,
was the Italian BK royal crispy chicken.
Let's get that picture up on the screen.
This would've been perfect for
"Food Wars," US versus Italy.
Couldn't get my hands on it.
Claudia, what do you think of this?
I don't know. That doesn't
look very Italian to me.
I think if you put crispy chicken,
that automatically makes it not Italian.
Let's talk about wraps.
We thought there were two.
Actually, the grilled
chicken is not there anymore,
so we just got this crispy one.
This wrap looks very sad.
I don't know. I feel
like you could do better
with the actual wrap itself.
Here's what's inside.
I don't know. The wrap is very pale.
BK also has wraps. You can
get pretty much each one
of these chicken sandwiches in wrap form.
I went ahead and got the
spicy BK royal crispy wrap.
I mean, all they're doing is taking --
oh, so it's half a patty.
Not even a full patty.
So you get half a patty and
all this stuff in wrap form.
Like, what's the draw of this?
If you want a wrap,
just go someplace else.
Couple other exclusive
items that we got here.
You can get a taco at Burger King.
I love tacos just as much as the next guy,
but, I mean, look how thin this is.
It looks like the guy sat on
it before he gave it to us.
I'm curious.
I can't be sure, but I think they put
the barbecue sauce in there.
That can't be right. If
they did, that's terrible.
Whatever it is, it's bad. Don't get it.
This right here is the big fish.
Look at this thing. What a nightmare.
They put pickles on it? Guys, come on.
Pickles on a fish sandwich.
I really like the Filet-O-Fish.
I should say that right now.
I think it's a tasty sandwich.
I don't know what they're putting
in the Filet-O-Fish at McDonald's,
probably not a lot of fish,
but I think it's very good.
My favorite thing about the Filet-O-Fish
is their tartar sauce. It
makes and breaks the sandwich.
For them, tartar sauce,
fantastic, so one would assume
that this square fish patty,
correct me I'm wrong, but
no fish is naturally square,
so this highly processed fish patty
is drowning in a white sauce
that should be a tartar sauce,
and we're going to find
out if it's any good.
It's a thicker bun,
so it feels like you're
getting more sandwich.
Yeah, I actually kind of like that.
I don't think it's better tasting
than the Filet-O-Fish, but
it's still pretty good.
Let's see what is in
Italy's king junior meal.
As a main course, you can
either get a four-piece nugget,
a chicken burger, a
hamburger, a cheeseburger,
or a toast, which is what we got today.
And then you also get
fries, a mini Kit Kat,
a drink, and a toy.
Let's see what's inside ours.
Here's our toast.
Tiny fries, cute,
Kit Kat,
the drink obviously,
and a toy.
What is this? It looks like a glass.
It doesn't really look like something
you would give to your child
if you were making their lunch.
It is the plainest thing that you can get,
and usually parents are a little bit wary
of giving sauces and
things that are too rich.
Kids-meal options in the
US, aka the king junior.
You can get either a cheeseburger
or a four-piece nugget.
I think we got the nuggets.
And then your options are either fries,
onion rings, or applesauce.
They have a drink cup that is reusable.
I think it's pretty nice.
And you can also get milk.
See it says "Jr." right there?
And for a toy,
a spoon.
No. The toy, they got nothing.
I don't know if they
forgot to give us a toy,
or maybe they don't have toys?
What?
Oh, you think because
I ordered as an adult,
they're like, "He doesn't want a toy"?
What, all work and no play for the J-man?
Come on, I want a toy!
I think maybe, though,
you think the puzzle's the toy on the bag?
I don't know.
I don't think the spoon's the toy.
So either they forgot the
toy or you don't get one.
We didn't get one.
Exclusive sides we have,
these are two of them.
One thing I want to point
everyone's attention to
are these chicken fries.
That's right, chicken
strips shaped like fries.
Interesting fact about this box,
see how it kind of gets smaller here?
This box was designed specifically
to fit in a car cup holder,
because here in America,
God forbid we stop and eat a meal.
We have to eat and do something else.
I think it's very funny
considering in Italy,
it's like the meal is the event.
Now, it's a chicken fry.
It's more of a marketing
thing to call this a fry,
because it's not a chicken tender,
because tenders come from a
specific part of the chicken.
The fry is more like a chicken finger,
where it's made with whole muscle meat.
They're really durable.
They're really elastic.
Don't you think if you're waving
a piece of chicken like this,
it would've broken off by now?
Look at this! Look at this!
Why is this so like this?
I think they taste fine.
It's just a weird thing
to be on the menu still.
I mean, I don't know
anyone who's getting these.
Mozzarella sticks.
We should've asked Claudia before.
Do mozzarella sticks even exist in Italy?
I want to know. Because here in the US,
you can get these as a four-piece
or an eight-piece with marinara sauce.
These have been sitting for a while,
but of course I'm wondering
what kind of cheese pull
we can get from these mozzarella sticks.
Eh, eh, oh, OK, OK.
Oh, not a bad one. They're just OK.
These are our exclusive
sides here in Italy,
starting from these chili cheese bites.
You can get them in a
six-piece and a nine-piece.
Doesn't look like there's chili
in them. Let's try them out.
They taste a bit too peppery, I think.
I was expecting it just to taste spicy.
Like, they taste like fresh
chilies, which is nice,
but I'm not sure what cheese is this.
Then we've got plant-based
nuggets as a six-piece.
They look a bit green, like there's been,
like there's some filter on them.
They taste actually like nuggets.
I don't know if this is fake chicken
or it's just vegetables,
but they're quite good,
and from the inside they
look like normal ones.
You can then get bacon king
fries with cheddar sauce.
You can also get them
without cheddar sauce.
But here's the ones we've got.
You can also get chicken wings
in a four-piece and a eight-piece.
Here's how they look like.
Just very tiny wings.
When I was little, we used to
go and vacation in this town
in the south of Italy
in a very small village,
and the whole village
on the 15th of August
was celebrating with something
that we call the Alata.
Ala means wing in Italian.
And it was just a big chicken-wings party.
The ones I'm used to, they
were a little bit bigger
and a bit more light colored.
Let's see how this one tastes like.
Ooh, spicy.
It's a bit, yeah, a bit of a spicy sauce.
Yeah, there's a lot of pepper in there.
No, not a fan.
Then you can get two types of toast,
the king toast with Swiss cheese and ham.
This is the same as in the kids menu.
And then you can get it with
bacon and American cheese.
And then we've got griller fries,
or maybe you call these waffle fries.
But we actually have some
packaged chips in Italy
that are sold with this shape.
Perhaps that's why they
went with the fries.
There is a tiny bit of spice
in the aftertaste. Quite nice.
They're doing waffle fries in Italy.
That's a direct rip-off
of the Chick-fil-A fries!
Like, this company is shameless!
If it's popular somewhere
else, Burger King has it.
That's their new slogan.
And then we also have
salads here in Italy.
Technically there are four options,
but we were only able to get two.
So the four options
are just a mixed salad,
crispy chicken, grilled chicken,
and a tuna salad,
which doesn't seem like something
I would like to get at Burger King.
Here we have a mixed salad.
One thing I just, why
are you serving the salad
with a whole tomato?
Who eats this? Like, why?
And we have another one here
which was supposed to be the
grilled chicken, I think,
but it's another one of those mixed salads
with those huge tomatoes.
The salads can also come
with some olive oil.
It was actually given to
us in a little sachet,
but we can't find it.
Sauce talk.
Discurso de la salsa.
Here are all the sauces
that are exclusive to Italy.
Well, technically exclusive
because they're all from Heinz,
so you won't find these in the US.
Heinz makes all the sources here in Italy.
We start from ketchup,
then mayo, barbecue,
sweet and sour sauce, curry mango sauce.
Then we've got spicy tomato salsa,
which, hm, sounds interesting.
And then we've got cream honey mustard.
The last one, which is not
made by Heinz, is Nocciolata.
This is technically not a sauce.
It's a hazelnuts and chocolate spread,
a bit like Nutella.
Yeah, this one, Rigoni di Asiago,
is, some people will
say, the posh Nutella.
It's a very nice and rich spread.
Let's see, mango and curry.
The color I was expecting.
Nice. I'm surprised it's on the menu.
Yeah, it does taste like
curry-inspired sauce
and sweet, so maybe there is mango.
I love the looks of the mango curry.
I definitely want one of those.
Can you please send it to me? Thank you.
Here are pretty much all the
sauces you can get in the US,
since they're not Heinz
products, at least not labeled.
Do you think Burger King
makes their own sauces,
or do you think they're
just going to the source
and putting their own labels on it?
I have no idea. Here we
got a barbecue sauce.
I would love to try, when I go to Europe,
like that's happening anytime soon,
when I go to Europe, I want
to try their barbecue sauce.
Because I feel like what
they think is barbecue
and what we call barbecue
can't be the same.
That's a sweet barbecue sauce.
I'd liken it to a Kansas
City barbecue. Very good.
This is the zesty sauce.
This tastes like a strong
mustard, not honey mustard,
but sweeter than a regular mustard.
Actually, it's closer to a Dijon.
It just says spices.
Doesn't say which ones.
No. It's not bad, just, I don't want that.
Sweet and sour sauce.
Come on! Open like a normal --
imagine if I was driving,
trying to eat my chicken, ah!
I'd be on the opposite
side of the road by now,
crashing into everyone.
I'd be driving on the sidewalk
trying to open this sauce.
All right, sweet and sour, come on.
Buffalo sauce. For those
of you not in America,
Buffalo sauce is named
after Buffalo hot wings.
It's a type of spicy sauce, mm,
you get wings, and now it's on everything,
and no, it does not taste like buffaloes.
It's from Buffalo, New
York, where the sauce was,
the recipe was made or
perfected, I don't know.
It's basically hot wing sauce.
I like Buffalo sauce.
I don't think -- it's
only good on chicken.
On burgers or fries or
dipping, doesn't work.
Last we got ranch.
This country is obsessed with ranch.
I don't know why. It's kind of weird.
But we got everyone in America,
including Burger King, so,
ee!
Ranchy.
And this is Heinz ketchup.
Wait, we have Heinz ketchup,
and they have Heinz ketchup,
so this isn't an exclusive.
But these sauces are.
Biscuits. Here in the US, we
have a specific type of biscuit
that is not a cookie or a
scone, it's its own thing.
Anyway, we can get just about
every breakfast sandwich
at Burger King in biscuit form.
There's the bacon, egg,
and cheese biscuit;
sausage, egg, and cheese biscuit;
smoky maple chicken biscuit;
the ham, egg, and cheese biscuit;
the egg and cheese biscuit;
and the fully loaded biscuit.
I'm not getting all of them.
It's a waste. Here's two.
I got the bacon, egg, and cheese biscuit.
Personally, I think when it
comes to breakfast sandwich,
bacon, egg, and cheese
is the gold standard.
You can maybe do it a different way,
but I think bacon, egg, and cheese
is pretty much the best
breakfast sandwich to get.
Here it is. There's your egg.
There's your bacon and
cheese. There's the biscuit.
It's very dry. I don't
feel like trying it.
And then also the fully
loaded one. This is hilarious.
Want to get this? This has got
a little bit of everything.
Got the egg, got the sausage, got the ham,
got the cheese, and the bacon.
How does this look, Italy? Huh?
Breakfast is served. Let's go!
Not only do we have that in biscuit form,
we have the same exact type
of sandwiches in croissant,
excuse me, Croissan'wich form.
Once again, Italy, your
neighbors to the north,
France, they invented the croissant.
I'm sure all through Europe
you have amazing pastries,
including croissants.
Here in the US, we've
absolutely ruined them
by cutting them in half
and sticking meat and
cheese in the middle.
So here we go. We got the
bacon, egg, and cheese.
Again, the gold standard.
You can also get a ham, egg, and cheese;
egg and cheese; smoky maple
chicken Croissan'wich.
God, that sounds horrible.
Double sausage, egg, and
cheese, I forgot about that.
That's two patties of
sausage, two slices of cheese,
double the diarrhea in the morning.
And of course, the fully
loaded Croissan'wich.
Our cricket buddy is back.
We will try to remove the
cricket audio in post,
but sorry, everyone, we're filming this
in the middle of the woods, apparently.
We have sausage, egg, ham, bacon, cheese,
oh, God.
[cricket chirping]
Cricket, do you want a bite of this?
We also have breakfast burritos.
This here is the Egg-Normous Burrito,
which has bacon, egg, cheese,
a hash brown, and a spicy sauce.
This is for someone who
just wants your first hour
once you punch in at
work to be on the toilet.
So if you're looking to
poop on company time,
maybe grab one of these
on the way to work.
Look at this.
Guys, this is like,
oh, I don't even know what this is like.
I've never seen anything like this.
So of course I have to try it.
Nope.
Gross.
And this next one is a
breakfast burrito junior.
So this one's for kids. Want
to get them started young!
Look what they did!
They put a hash brown at
the beginning and the end.
So you're going to be like,
"Oh, it must be loaded with hash browns.
Mm-mm, one at the entrance
and the exit. Nice try.
Also in the US we're crazy about pancakes,
and we have the pancake platter
and the pancake and sausage platter,
currently unavailable at
the Burbank Burger King.
In Italy, we actually don't have
a breakfast menu at Burger King.
To be honest, I don't think Italians
would like to have what
Joe has in his menu.
Like, a croissant filled
with bacon and eggs
doesn't seem quite right.
I think most of us just
have a sweet breakfast
that usually is just
a pastry and a coffee.
It can be a very calorific pastry
with a lot of Nutella or another filling,
but usually it's always sweet.
Sounds like Claudia is implying
that Italians like something
a little more sweet,
a baked good for breakfast.
So, we do have some of those in the US,
and we do have some of those
obviously at Burger King.
Going on down here, starting off,
we got French toast sticks.
France, as you are aware, is a country
that's right above Italy, and
they have their own toast,
and we have that in stick
form, and this is them.
And it also comes with a dipping syrup.
What's more French than that?
Look at this. Look at this.
I know it's "Food Wars" Italy,
but "Food Wars" France has gotta
be right around the corner.
Any French person watching this right now
is going to have a heart attack.
But yeah, you know, I mean.
You have no idea how sweet this is.
Also, we have these hash brown
bites, these little guys.
Desserts, sweets!
Oh, how we have it in the
US at our Burger King.
You can get a Hershey's sundae pie.
Not Sunday day of the week.
Sundae as in a
ice cream sundae, right?
And I mean, I mean, look at this.
Look at this! Right?
Look at this, how gooey
that is. Ooh! Come on.
Also at Burger King, you can
get soft-serve ice cream.
I didn't get it because
we've been in the studio
for a couple hours and it's very hot,
and it would've melt.
Anyway, you can also get
chocolate chip cookies,
hey!
And a variety of shakes, a vanilla shake,
a chocolate shake, a chocolate Oreo shake,
and this, the Oreo shake.
Every time we do a fast-food place
that has a shake, the
Oreo shake, I get it.
I think that Oreo, as far as
branded cookie snack shakes
you get at a lot of
these fast-food places,
the Oreo is the best one.
Why, do you ask?
Looks like a vanilla and
chocolate shake, right? Wrong.
It isn't vanilla, it's the
Oreo-cream-flavored shake
with Oreo chocolate cookies in it.
Just, I'm telling you,
oh, my God, so good.
Oreo is the best shake, hands down.
Mm!
So, on to the dessert
options here in Italy,
these are the ones that
we were able to get,
but actually there are a bunch of others,
and we're going to put
them all on screen here.
That includes a lot of
ice cream, like sundaes
and milkshakes, but we
were not able to get them.
So this is what we've got today.
We've got Nocciolata pancakes,
and then we've got nutty cheesecake,
crown caramel soufflé.
I think if you call something
lava cake, you will expect,
I mean, I'm sure, like,
half of your customers
will think that you
actually put lava in there.
Yeah, and I was saying earlier,
Nocciolata is actually a very
popular spread here in Italy.
It's a hazelnut and chocolate spread.
I was expecting it to be much thicker.
Let's see.
Quite nice.
Yeah, the pancakes are OK.
It's really delicious.
It tastes much stronger,
much more like hazelnuts
than Nutella does.
Like, these two are competitors.
Approved.
We can also get some milkshakes.
The exclusive ones are
Nesquik, Nescafé, and Oreo.
Drinks in the US Burger
King, we have a lot.
Fountain drinks, for instance.
It's a fountain-drink cup.
I wasn't going to get all these
because it's just super hot,
and it's a pain in the
butt to get the stuff here.
All the other drinks have melted.
I told you I'm wearing this
shirt. It's hot in here!
We have something called frozen drinks.
You can get a frozen Coke
and a frozen wild cherry
and also a frozen blue raspberry,
which is not available.
This was more of a slush consistency
before it melted in this
80-degree studio. What?
Oh, we also got milk. OK.
Anyway, I mean, not bad.
I mean, it's still pretty cold.
But, yeah, usually this is
a lot more icelike, icy.
There's a wild cherry, oh, yeah.
We have coffee drinks. You
can get an iced coffee,
this used to have ice
in it, and a hot coffee.
And, of course, who doesn't like to relax
with a room-temperature fat-free milk?
That'll wash down your burger.
Here are all the drinks
that are exclusive to Italy Burger King,
starting from this very
cute Pago orange juice.
Then we got some tea.
We've got peach and rose, fancy,
and lemon and lemongrass.
We've got Monster Energy,
which has been delivered
in a bit of a funny shape.
And then we've got beer.
You can either get Heineken or Ichnusa,
which is a Sardinian beer.
Some Burger Kings will also
serve a full range of coffees,
espresso coffees, because
that's what coffee means to us.
But because we got our
food and drinks delivered,
we actually were not
able to select coffee,
so we couldn't get any today.
Burger King, in my point of view,
is like fast food's little brother.
It's always trying to
be like the big dogs.
It's always trying to be like McDonald's.
It's always like whatever is good,
Burger King has kind of a
later, crummier version of it.
Now, I will say, the Whopper
is a fantastic sandwich.
I love the Whopper. I get it occasionally.
But everything else on Burger
King's menu, thumbs down,
or at least there's something else
that's better than
whatever they're offering.
You know, Burger King, I only eat there
when it's the ultimate
convenience, which is rare,
because I don't know if a lot of people
outside of the US knew this,
but Burger King's strategy
is to build a location
close to a McDonald's.
Did you know that? So McDonald's
does all this research
about where to position their
restaurants strategically,
you know, traffic patterns,
rent and locations, all that stuff.
McDonald's has a whole
department of people
to figure that out, and
then Burger King's like,
"All right, we'll build
one across the street
from that McDonald's." That's for real!
Like, that's their vibe on everything.
So I don't know what it's
like in other countries,
but in Burger King, you're
just like, "Oh, Burger King."
In Italy, I think Burger King
goes pretty much hand
in hand with McDonald's.
Obviously it's been there
for a little bit less time.
Burger King is quite popular in Italy.
They currently have 232 outlets.
KFC has only got 50
branches here in Italy.
Although they are still behind McDonald's.
That has 630 branches.
Like, some of us have, most of us
have celebrated birthdays at McDonald's.
So obviously we do have some memories
and something that brings us back to it.
I think it's also a
little bit more expensive
compared to McDonald's, and
maybe that's one of the reasons
why people would choose
one instead of the other.
Even though there are some
Italian ingredients in the menu,
Burger King is still
pretty much considered
the American option or, like,
the American fast-food chain,
whereas McDonald's has sort of
got rid of the "American" fast-food chain.
It's just the fast-food
chain, if that makes sense.
They are the first chain that has removed
preservatives and colorants from food,
but there are quite a few
items that we've seen today
that look very shiny and very colorful,
and I would really like to know,
how do you make your cheese
so yellow without colorants?
Like, why? Like, how is that
even possible naturally?
Rivals, I don't know, would you
consider McDonald's a rival?
That's like me saying The Rock's my rival.
Like, yeah, rivals, but, like, come on.
I don't think he's sweating
that I'm out there doing videos as well.
There's no, no one's, I
mean, Wendy's, I guess.
Let's talk about prices.
In Italy, a Whopper is 6 euros, 50 cents,
which is about $7.27.
If you want to make that a
meal with a medium-sized drink
and medium fries, that's
going to cost you 11 euros,
and that's about $12.30.
And in the US, a Whopper
will cost you $6.89,
or 6 euros and 16 eurobytes.
I don't know what the, what? Is it cents?
All right, everyone, relax. It's cents.
There you go, all right.
[beep]
So 6 euros and 16 cents.
Now, that's a 6% decrease in
price. How do you like that?
If you're making a meal
with a medium fries
and medium drink, it'll cost you $12.18,
or 10 euros and 95 eurocents.
So, it actually works out
cheaper to get a Whopper meal
in the US rather than in
Italy, but just by a few cents.
12 bucks? Uh,
I guess I'm used to it,
but come to think of it,
it's a lot more expensive
than what I initially thought.
Yeah, I mean, I don't even
think it's that good of a deal.
It's not, like, too expensive,
but I think almost 13 bucks or whatever,
12-something plus tax for all this
is like, ugh, might as
well get something better.
The prices seem fair.
It is a little bit more
expensive than McDonald's,
but also the burgers
are a little bit bigger,
and it's definitely almost half the price
as, like, a Five Guys.
I think 11 euros is fair,
but if you start getting
close to, like, 15,
that's where I think
I would like to sit down at a restaurant,
and that's probably the
price of a main course,
like a restaurant here in Milan.
So 11 euros was just below,
just below the restaurant line, let's say.
As the Whopper is Burger
King's No. 1 bestselling item,
we thought we would
compare them nutritionally.
In Italy, a Whopper contains 683 calories.
Our US Whopper contains all this.
If you make that a meal
by adding medium fries
and a medium Coke, the total is this.
Making the grand total this.
The most calorific item on the menu here
is the bacon king 3.0,
at 1,342 calories.
That is a lot for a burger.
Our bacon king is also the
most calorific single item
on the menu, at 1,200 calories. Oof.
Also at Burger King, you can
get soft-serve ice cream.
I didn't get it because
we've been in the studio
for a couple hours and it's
very hot and it would've melt.
How hot, you ask?
You can't tell, but this
shirt is actually a shirt
that I work out and go running in.
I don't know if you can
see the label on there.
Zoom in on that.
I'm wearing athleisure wear for this job.